unlock the power of databases with this
MySQL course for beginners whether
you're new to databases or looking to
level up your skills this course has you
covered you'll learn how to create
manage and manipulate data using MySQL
you'll discover the secrets of keys
learn to write queries like a pro and
automate tasks with triggers no jargon
just practical knowledge Josh from
keepit techie teaches this course he
works as a SQL Server database
administrator so he's the perfect person
to teach this course what's up guys this
Josh from keep techi and welcome to my
comprehensive course on MySQL now MySQL
is a relational database management
system and in this course I'll try to
explore the ins and outs of my SQL on
Rocky Linux which is a powerful
combination for managing your data
effectively now my SQL is not just any
database it's the fundamental Port of
the lamp stack which stands for Linux
Apache MySQL and PHP and then also the
limp stack which is Linux engine X MySQL
and PHP and these Stacks are widely used
for Content Management Systems like
WordPress jumer and various other web
applications and I'll start with the
basics covering the installation login
procedures and a little bit of database
management so whether you're a beginner
or have some experience this course will
help you master my SQL on this fantastic
Linux distribution so let's head over to
to Rocky Linux 9 server and get started
with the installation process okay so
here we are logged into Rocky Linux 99
server and to install my SQL we'll
follow these simple steps and I just
brought up the OS release information
under so you guys can see that I am on
Rocky Linux 9 which is a one toone
comparison to Red Hat 9 so let's go on
and clear and first let's ensure that
our system is up to date and we need to
run the following command to refresh the
package repositories and apply any
available updates and that command is
pseudo dnf and update and we'll wait for
this to finish but this will basically
check to see if there is any updates and
if there are it'll upgrade those
packages on the server and as you can
see we don't have any updates so we're
good to go I believe I updated this
before I started this video so now to
install my SQL all we have to do is type
pseudo dnf install and then my SQL
server and I'll just tab it out it'll
pull up the latest version of my SQL so
that's basically the version number and
all that stuff for this actual package
so let's go on press enter that'll go
through and resolve all the dependencies
for MySQL as well as the package for
MySQL so all we have to do is type why
for yes we want to install this package
and use the amount of space that it will
use use on the operating system so
scroll on press enter it'll go through
like I said download all those
dependencies as well as the MySQL server
package and then install it on the
system so I'll be back when it finishes
all right so the installation is
complete and now we need to check the
MySQL Services status and we can do that
by using the system CTL command so let's
type pseudo system CTL and one thing I
noticed on Rocky Linux it doesn't start
the service after the installation or
part of the installation process similar
to like you buntu typically when you
install MySQL it'll go down and start
the service and you may have to go in
and enable the service but most of the
time it starts the service right off but
on Rocky Linux or rail it doesn't so
system CTL and then status and then what
we want to do is check that my SQL
status and you'll see that it's not
started boom and it'll say right here
where where it says active it says
inactive so right now that lets you know
that it's not started and then also Al
the enabled portion of it this is
essentially for when you reboot the
server itself that service will store it
up right now it's disabled we want to
enable that so it's two commands we can
run right fast we basically have to run
the pseudo system CTL start and this
will start the actual service so let's
go and press enter all right and so we
can run the status command again and
this will show you that that service is
running now so as you can see it says
active and running but we still need to
enable it so let's let's go down and
press Q that'll drop us back down to the
terminal again and we get up arrow and
then let's remove the status and type
enable press enter and it'll go through
and enable This Server so each time you
reboot your Rocky Linux server my SQL
will stored and so let's check the
status again we can go back in here and
look at it and this is what we're
looking for where it says enabled that
lets you know it's enabled so that
service is stored up and so that's
pretty much it we've successfully
installed my SQL and now it's time to
show you you guys how to log into it and
you use a command called MySQL and you
also want to put the user account and if
there is a password then you want to put
that password there as well or the
option to ask for a password but since
this root account that's on the system
of the default root account it doesn't
have a password you can log right in and
so let me go down and type the command
in and we are using a pseudo account so
we have to type pseudo in order to run
the MySQL command so let's type pseudo
MySQL and then we need to put our user
so we have to put our option in there-
you and then the username so I'm going
to use that that root account like I
said that's the default account that's
there after installation and it doesn't
have a password on there but we need to
put- P at the end of it so it will
access for the password and you'll see
once we get past this step It'll ask for
the password but we don't have to put a
password in because there is no password
set for it now I want to point this out
to you as well though you want to make
sure you follow best practices and
create a dedicated user account for your
projects you don't want to be using this
root account with no password on it so
go on and press enter It'll ask you for
a password it says enter password and
since we ran pseudo it normally will ask
you for a pseudo account so if you you
may see it asking for the pseudo account
so you want to type that in of course
but then it'll pop up with this enter
password for the MySQL account so I just
want to know let you guys know that the
way you're seeing it on mine it may not
show up on yours you might have to type
in a password for pseudo
and then press enter because there is no
password so let's press enter right fast
and that'll get us into our MySQL server
now that we're in let's explore some
basic MySQL commands and functionality
now once you're inside the MySQL prompt
which is what it's showing right here
with the my SQL and then that right
arrow you can begin executing commands
and so let me walk you guys through a
few ones the first one you need to know
is the help command so if we type help
and then every command pretty much every
command you have to type a semicolon
behind it similar to typing out a query
in order for it to run that statement
for you so help will basically give you
a whole bunch of information on how to
use my SQL if you scroll through here
you'll see a Le list of all MySQL
commands and some of these commands they
use that left slash in front of it and
that's what I was going to show you guys
as well after this by typeing help you
know as one word and then the semicolon
there's another way of actually getting
to the help and that's the back SL and H
but the other ones are there and they
have an explanation of what they
actually do and I won't go through them
all cuz I typically don't use a lot of
these commands these my SQL commands
right here but I just wanted to show you
guys where to get that information from
if you need it now let me go to and run
that back slash and then H and that way
you guys can look at the same thing and
it looks like it didn't change because
it just basically ran it again and
display the same information so we are
good to go now the first thing I wanted
to show you guys is how to to find
databases within your database
management system and so I'll show you
guys that command now and it's
essentially the show command so all we
have to do is type show and then we want
to type what we what we're looking for
which is databases so databases with an
S and then semic calling at the end of
it and this will show you all the
databases that are currently on the
system so let's go down and press enter
and what you'll see is some built-in
databases for the database management
system like information schema like the
performance schema this my SQL database
as well as the cyst database and I
recommend you don't touch any of those
those are vital to the system running
properly but this is how you actually
look at all the databases that are on
the system all right so now that we know
how to look at the databases that are
currently on the system I wanted to show
you guys how to create a database cuz
this is like one of the most important
steps after that because we need to
understand how to create those databases
so all we have to do is type create and
a lot of these commands you'll you'll
start remembering them almost like a
sentence cuz that's essentially what it
is like show databases simple you know
create database so we want to create a
database and that's the command right
there so create database with no s cuz
it's singular you know so no s is needed
and then the database name so we can
name it whatever we want to I'm going
just do DB name and then put a semicolon
at the end of it and go down and press
and it'll create our database as you can
see query okay one row affected so and
what row they're talking about is the
built-in table that list out all the
databases that are in the database
management system so we can go back and
look at that show database command show
databases command and we'll see that
that new database is there is called DB
name that's what we named it now
probably the next question you have is
how do I create tables within the
database that we just created and I need
to show you another C command beforehand
and you need to specify the database you
want to run queries against by using the
use command so like I said almost like a
sentence you just type use and we want
to use a specific database and which
database we want to use is that DB name
and then you can end out your sentence
with the semicolon and press enter and
this will make a change so that we are
using database name for the following
commands and you need to do that every
single time so my SQL will know what
database you're creating things with or
even running other queries like select
or update it needs to know what database
is working with so you have to use this
command in order to change it to the
database that you want to work with and
now I'm going to show you guys how to
create a table and like I said it's
almost like a sentence so create table
and then we want to create a table name
so we have to name that table so I'm
going just name it employees now this is
a little bit more complicated because it
requires multiple lines so after this we
have to specify each one of the columns
within that table and you can press
enter in here and that's why it's
important to understand the purpose of
that semicolon that closes out your
query until you type that semicolon it
will not close out the query so let's go
down and press enter boom and as you can
see it'll go to the next line allowing
you to type some more information and we
want to go through and create each one
of the columns within our database and
so the first one is
employee ID a lot of times when you
create a table you want to create what
they call a primary key and this is a
unique identifier for each row of data
within the database and that just keeps
things a little bit more cleaner in the
database as well as a way to make sure
we don't have any duplicate information
and if the information is duplicate in
other columns it will still recognize it
as a different record so the next thing
we want to use is integer so this is an
integer meaning a number so and then
also with our primary key there's an
option you can put here called
autoincrement and this will allow it to
create numbers in sequence so 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 89 10 it will you know keep going as
new records are added to the database or
to the table and so let's type that in
right fast so autocore increment and
then also this is a primary so we have
to type that out as well and then we
have to put a Comm at the end of it
that'll let us know that that is one of
the columns within our table and then we
can press enter and we can type in our
next column and let's start off with
first name and just like the init we
have to specify what type of characters
are in it the init is integer like I
said that's a number well this is a
variable you know all those letters and
so we have to type V chore and then we
can specify the amount of characters
that you can type within that and so the
default is like 255 you'll see a lot of
people put 255 so that's a good length
for the amount of characters that can be
put into it and then we can also specify
that this column should always have
information in it you don't you can't
create another row unless information is
in that field within that column so
let's go type not null and that's what
that mean null meaning not empty or
blank and so we can type a comma at the
end of it and let's go on and type in
our next column which I go with lastore
name and then same thing so V chore and
then 255
and we can close that out and then not
all as well for that one hit a comma and
let's do one more and that'll be the
birth date of our employee so that's
just some information we want to put in
there for this table or require for this
table and then we can put dates and then
we could leave it not and all off
because we don't need the birthday I'm
going just I'm just showing you guys
that and then once it's the last one you
don't have to put a comma at the end of
it but we do have to press enter and
close out these parentheses if you open
a parentheses you need to close it so
let's go on and close it right fast and
then what is the last thing I'm sure you
guys remember but is the semicolon that
will close out your query and so all of
this information here it will create
each one of the columns within that
table so it'll create the table and then
it'll create all the columns within that
table here so let's go and press enter
and as long as you see query okay zero
rows affected that means it successfully
created that table and so now we have
that employees table within the database
we can check the structure of it to
verify that we typed it in correctly by
using the describe commands so let's go
on and type describe and then our table
so it is the employees table and of
course at the end of each statement you
have to put that semicolon at the end of
it and this will give you information
about this table so as you can see the
fills we got our fills our different
columns within the table and we got
employee ID then it's uh integer and
then null and then this is the primary
key and then also this is auto increment
you'll see that listed there and this
will break down basically the structure
of this table so this is what that
describe is for now I won't go into
adding data yet but I'll show you guys
how to drop this table and with my SQL
or with SQL the actual language that
we're using drop is actually how you
delete something within the database so
let's say we want to drop that employees
table that we just created so all we
have to do is type drop and then we want
to specify that we want to drop a table
and then the table name so like I said
employees and then type a semicolon at
the end and this will drop that table
and I forgot before I drop that table I
wanted to show you guys something now so
I'm going just press uh up arrow and
find that create table employees table
and I'm going bring it back right fast
so let's press enter and of course
that's one way of showing you guys you
could type this out without the separate
lines it's just easier to see if you put
it on a separate line you see what I'm
saying but you could type it out just
like that the way it's listed there so I
wanted to show you guys the show tables
command and let's go on and type that in
so show tables and like I said we're
still using that DB name database and so
let's go on and press enter boom and
that will show you the actual table
that's there and now let's go back and
remove that table I'm going to drop it
again so drop table employees boom and
then we can run that show tables again
and this will show you that there are no
more tables on there so I didn't want to
move forward without showing you guys
that now the last thing I want to show
you guys is how to actually drop a
database and essentially that's deleting
the entire database just like we deleted
the entire table we can delete the
entire database so let's go on and type
that command in right fast but it's
simply drop and then database and like I
said it's just like a sentence and then
we need to specify that database name so
DB name and then semic at the end of it
press enter and that will drop that
database and now we can type show
databases and then the semicolon at the
end of it and press enter and this will
let you verify that that name database
is gone so you won't see it anymore so
we get to go now be very cautious when
running that command because it will
remove all tables and data within that
database so just be very careful with it
okay so moving on to the next part of
the course we need to have a database
with lots of data so you can see
examples clearly and I'm going to import
a test database name to inlo and this is
on GitHub and let me switch over to my
browser so you guys can see the link and
if you want to do the same you can find
a link in the description to import the
database and this database was created
by bik base on GitHub and like I said
I'll have the link so you can get here
but let me just show you guys the
directory structure so so they have a
MySQL dump that you can import and this
will generate a full SQL database for
you it's called the employees database
so if we go under MySQL you can see they
have a postgress as well if you need a
PO example but MySQL is what we'll be
using and they have a data full or a
data set full data set large data set
small in the full we'll have the full
amount of data which is the one I
recommend you guys use they also have a
large which is a smaller version of the
f doesn't have as much data in it and
then the small is kind of like a sample
size of the data so you can use that as
well it really doesn't matter just pick
which one you want I'll import the data
set full essentially what we're going to
do is install this data dump it's a SQL
dump and I'll get to this in a later
part of the video where I show you guys
how to back up databases and import
databases or restore databases but this
is the five whee import and let me go
down and go here first and what I want
to do is clone this repository to the
server so we're going to copy that link
and then go back to our Ser server
terminal and exit out of my SQL so we
could just type exit and this is a good
time for me to show you guys how to exit
you could just type exit and press enter
and it'll get you out of my squel and
and now that we back at the terminal we
can go down and install get cuz we need
get installed so we can just type P sudo
dnf install and then get and press enter
type in our Pudo password boom and it'll
go through install G as well as all this
dependencies and we type why for yes
boom now go on and install get on our
system and now we can get clone that
actual repository and we don't need to
change directories we can use our home
directory and so all we have to do is
type get clone and then we can paste
that link and press enter and it'll
clone down that actual repository for us
and now we can import this test database
so first thing you need to do let's LS
right fast I show you guys the directory
but we need to CD into that directory
and we want to go
into my SQL and then we need to go into
the directory of the location of the
size of the database that you want to in
install so let's T it out right fast but
there is that full like I said so that's
the directory we need to go into now if
you want to go into the other ones you
just select large or the small one as
well you can select that one as well
like I said I'm going to do the full
boom press enter and if we LS this
directory this will show you all the
files that are in there and it's so
allow you to see the file that we want
to import and we need to use Pudo cuz
we're running MySQL under a regular
account which is that Josh account so we
get sudo my SQL and then what we want to
do is use the left arrow and then the
actual SQL file that we want to import
or the database that we want to import
which is that
employees. SQL file so scroll on press
enter this will take a little time
because the full is pretty big it has
about 300,000 records in at least in the
employee table and so it does take a
while let me go down and press enter
we're going to need this in order so I
can show you guys this information in a
better way as far as running the queries
and the different things I want to show
you guys in the examples it's best to
have a database with a lot of data in it
and this is the quickest and easiest way
to set that up and like I said this see
that table right there it says loading
employee that's the biggest table that's
in there and it's going to take a while
to actually import everything so I'll be
back when it finishes and then we can
log back in Sequel and go through the
more of the examples all right so the
import completed successfully it took
about 3 minutes and 57 seconds and so
let me show you guys how to test it
right fast I'm going LS this directory
again so you guys can see but there is a
test file in here it's a md5 hash test
so we can run this test by typing pseudo
MySQL and then- T and we need to put our
left arrow in there again and then that
testore employee md5 SQL and that will
test the actual database and just make
sure everything was imported
successfully on the server so just go on
and run it right fast and it'll have
some output you got you guys will see
and as long as you don't see any errors
that means everything was imported
successfully all right so the test is
complete and we can scroll through this
and just see that it it just verifies
that everything is okay so all the
records match you know what's supposed
to be imported when you run this thing
and as you can see it took a while cuz
this Server doesn't have many resources
assigned to it it would have ran a
little faster if I had more processing
power and probably a little bit more RAM
on the system but it's fine it ran
through and did it it's not affecting
you guys that's watching the video it's
only affecting me cuz this is the
computation time that it took all right
so let's go on the CD right fast just to
get out that directory we don't need to
and I'm going to clear again and let's
go on and get back in our my SQL
database so typees sudo my SQL dasu for
user and we want to go back into that
root account and d p press enter it'll
access for our shudo password boom and
it'll access for the password for the
rout and if you guys remember from
earlier there is no password set for the
root account so let's press enter
that'll get us in MySQL and then what I
wanted to do was show the databases so
that same command we ran earlier so show
databases semicolon at the end press
enter and we'll see that new database is
added to our server so we got the
employees database so now we can move on
to the rest of our examples of how to to
manage my SQL all right so the next
section I want to cover is managing user
accounts in my SQL and this is a very
important section because this basically
manages how people access your MySQL
server even applications how those
applications connect to your MySQL
server as well as the databases in it
and so the first thing I want to do is
show you guys how to create a new user
account and this allows you to control
who has access and can manage your
databases and and and so it's not that
difficult of a command and it's just
like I talked about in previous commands
it's almost like writing a sent and so
all you got to do is type create and
then user and then we have to put the
user information in there so we have to
put it in single quotes So the name
first so let's just name this DB user
and then after that quote we have to put
an at because you have to say how you
want this user to connect to the server
and you put this in single quotes as
well and this is considered the host
name and most most of the time you will
see Local Host which is what I'll use
currently and that basically means that
this user can connect to this my SQL
Server via Local Host so you have to be
connected to this server in order to
access this my SQL database and then
after that you want to give it a way to
access the server and that is via a
password so identifi so you have to type
it in properly just make sure you type
it in properly because I used to spell
this incorrectly a lot of times and I
ran into errors but it's identified by
and then our password which I'll just
put password to three and then close
these single quotes and then after that
for our SQL statement we have to close
it out by typing a semicolon at the end
of it and this will create our new user
account as you can see long as you don't
run into any errors it says query okay
zero row is affected you're good to go
you created that user account and like I
said earlier this command sets up a user
account with access limited to the local
host meaning that the user can only
connect to mySQL server from the same
system where MySQL is running and I just
wanted you guys understand that because
if you want to Grant access from let's
say another host and you have to replace
that Local Host with the remote machine
IP address so let's say you have an
application running on a application
server and you wanted that user account
to connect from that application server
cuz let's say this user account is what
allows that application to connect to
the my squ server you have to put that
IP address of where it's connecting from
otherwise it won't have access it'll
just have access via Local Host like it
states now there is a wild cord and the
wild cord it will allow access from any
host and let's go on and type it out
again so create user and I'll create
another user account so let's put it in
single quotes So DB user 2 and this is a
totally different account press the at
symbol and then the host we wanted to be
able to connect from I'll use that wild
cord and wild cord is the percent sign
and so that's uh shift five and then we
have to close those single quotes and
then next let's put identified by and
then we put our password so I'm going to
use that same password one two and then
our single quote to close it out and
then our semicolon to close that query
out and let's press enter we going run
into any issues we typed everything
correctly and this is considered that
wild cord now let's say you need to
change the SQL user accounts password
well let me walk you guys through that
query right now and it's using the alter
command and the way you do it is by
typing alter user and like I said it's
just like a sentence so alter user and
let's say we want to alter that DB user
that first one let's say we want to
change it to and then we have to type it
all out just make sure you type it all
out Local Host then single quote and
then identified so that's basically all
all you doing is typing it out the exact
same way we did to create that user but
you're using alter so identify by and
then we just type in a new password so
let's go password 456 and let's close
out those quotes and then the semicolon
at the end of it and press enter and
that will alter the password for it and
like I said as long as you don't see any
errors you get to go now another command
I want to show you guys is how to list
out all the MySQL user accounts and
there are some built-in user accounts
you obviously got that root one and you
got a couple more and you guys will see
them once I type in this next command so
we're going into select statement so
select user and then comma host and
basically we're selecting two columns
within a specific table and this is from
the MySQL do user table so let's go on
and uh put that cic colon at the end
press enter and it'll grab those two
columns for us and as you can see we can
see all our accounts that we created
even the new ones that we just created
so DB user is only accessible via the
Local Host and DB user 2 has that wild
card there and just to show you guys the
other accounts that are there so my.
infos schema I don't recommend you mess
around with any of these Accounts at
least until you understand fully what
they do but these three accounts are
systems accounts and then we got our
root account as well which we're logged
in using that now the next step is
deleting those user accounts so let's
say we want to delete the DB user
account so it's the same as with tables
and databases is the drop command and so
drop user and then the user account so
we have to put that in single quotes and
it's just like when we created it the
exact same format so DB user and let me
move the cursor out the way and then
close out that single quote then at and
then open up a single quote let me close
it right fast I always do that that's
just a habit but Local Host and then we
go back to the end and type that semi
colon at the end and press enter and
that will drop that so let's press the
up arrow and go back in here and select
those user accounts right fast from that
MySQL users table and you'll see that
that DB user is gone from the system now
let's test out this user account that we
still have available on the server and
so what I'm going to do is type exit
that'll get us out of that roote account
and let's run the MySQL command but
let's log in using the DB user 2 account
and so you basically type it in just
like we typed in for roots press enter
and then type in our pseudo password for
our Josh accounts just make sure you
understand that it's going to ask you
that for that password twice let's go
down and press enter and then now it's
going to ask you for the DB user 2
password which we set when we created
the account and that password was
password with a capital P and then 1 2 3
and press enter and that allow us to log
into my so now let me show you guys some
of the differences because right now
this account doesn't have any
permissions to any databases on the
server so let's run show databases and
then semicolon at the end and you guys
should see the difference we only see
two databases and these are the schema
databases that are built into my SQL and
so that lets you know that this user
account doesn't have access to any of
the databases on there and so I want to
go into the grant section of managing
these user accounts so let's go on and
exit out because we need to add some
permissions to this account so they can
actually see the databases or do certain
things to the database like select
statements and all that good stuff so
let's go on log back in using our root
accounts type in our password which is
nothing and let's go on and show that
those user accounts again on the system
so select user and then host at that my
SQL do user database that way we can
have a reference when we're typing
everything out so what we want to do is
Grant privileges to that user account so
all we have to do is type Grant and
there's a whole bunch of privileges that
could be set for a user account there's
all privileges you can set certain
things like alter they can only alter a
specific table they can create tables
create databases that's to create
privileges but what I'm going to do is
just do all privileges just show you
guys the base level of actually giving
an account and actually that's not the
base level I recommend you give the
least access that a user needs so if
they only need access to a specific
database and they only need to let's say
select certain things then you want to
just give it select permissions you
don't want want to give it a all
privileges if it doesn't need it for
that account but like I said I'm going
to just do all privileges just to make
it simple just so you guys can see but I
recommend you guys look at all the
different types of privileges so you can
understand them and give the least
privileges needed for the account so
privilege and make sure you type it in
right but that's Privileges and let's
say we only want to give them access to
a specific database well you put on that
database name and we'll use that
employee database it's employees and you
want to give it access to all the tables
so you just put a period and then the
store at the end of it that's like a
wild cord for all the tables under that
database and now we have to put in the
user account we want to apply this to so
that's why I say it's like a sentence
you know what I'm saying Grant all
privileges on this database all tables
to the user account and so that user
account is the DB user 2 and then at the
single quote and then wild cord single
quotes and then our semiot in and press
enter and it will grant those privileges
now let's go on exit out again cuz I I
just want to show you guys but if we log
back in under that user account that we
created so password 1 2 3 Center skip
back in it and let's run that show
databases command and see me coling at
the end press enter as you can see we
now have access to that employees
database let's go on exit out and get
back into our root account but I just
want to show you guys that's how you
grant those privileges now let's say you
want to Grant all priv is on all
databases let me go back up here to that
and all you have to do is put in a wild
cord so the wild cord in front of the
period and that specifies all databases
and all tables under each one of those
databases and so we got all those
permissions now so we can exit out and
then log back into that account and type
in our password again and press enter
and then let's show databases and this
is something you definitely don't want
to do I just want to show you guys that
you can do it you see how you can see
the other SQL database on here like
before we couldn't see my SQL or that
CIS database now we have access to see
pretty much all databases and all tables
and let's exit out go back into our root
accounts boom and it doesn't make sense
to go through everything so I'll just
show you guys a few other things let's
say you wanted to go employee database
and I know one of the specific tables in
there is department and so employee
Department you only want this user to
have access to just that database with
that table
you only want that user to have access
to that specific thing like I said you
can narrow this down you know deep so
people only have or user accounts only
have access to specific ports of a
database this can be accomplished by
typing out the commands like this and
then I won't run this I'll just go back
in let's put a store in there cuz I
wanted to show you guys something else
but let's say you instead of graning all
privileges to This Server we can go back
in here remove those privileges and we
can add a whole bunch of other
privileges so we could just do select
let's say you want to do a insert and
then you can also put like delete and
then on you know this database and all
tables so you can narrow down like I
said even more with this grant command
and let me just go to run that and just
see what happens and let's actually exit
it out I want to see what it looks like
uh when we go over there boom I want to
see if it removed all the other
privileges so let's log in and then run
these
databases and semicolon boom and we can
see all the table so it still has those
permissions for all the databases so you
might want to run a revoke before that
and then run it so it specifies okay
that makes sense so it still has that
those settings still there for all
privileges all tables so let's exit out
and now let's walk through how to revoke
permissions so this is an important part
you want to revoke permissions or at
least understand how to revoke voke all
privileges for a specific user and we'll
go through and do that for this account
and let's go back in here and select all
the user accounts I always like to do
that so I can have a reference when I'm
typing out things so I don't mess up
misspell certain things but the command
is revoke and revoke all privileges on
and I'm going actually put store there
as for all databases and then period all
tables and then from that specific
account which is our DB and forgot about
our quotes but yeah single quotes in
there make sure you type that in and
then this this one has the wild cord on
the end of it so we'll type it out
exactly how it is up there so from that
user account on this server so let's go
on and press enter and we forgot about
our semicolon so if you do forget about
it it'll bring it up on a second line
you can just type in the semicolon press
enter and it run the query and so let's
exit out again I know I keep jumping
back and forth but I just want to verify
a lot of this stuff and that I'm showing
you guys the right thing and I want you
guys to follow along so you can get used
to it cuz once you start typing these
commands out you get the hang of it you
know fairly quickly so let's go on and
type out our show databases again and
then put that semic colon at the end
boom you'll see we don't have access to
any of the databases on the server and
then let's exit out and what I want to
do is show you guys something else after
this let's log back in our root account
and Grant some privileges again and I
want to get real specific with this
account and that way the next command I
show you guys will make a lot more sense
and so let's grants and then select and
let's also do that insert as well and
then the delete on the employees
database and let's get that departments
table within that database and it's not
a s now that I think about it it's not a
s and then let's hpe two and then our
user account which is that that DB user
to and then at then a wild card and then
the see me coling at the end and press
enter and it'll Grant those specific
permissions for that user account and
now let me show you guys the last
command which is the show grants so we
can show all the grants that we have for
a specific user so and let type it in
correctly and we have to type in that
user account the exact same way so DB
user 2 and then at our wild cord and
then the semicolon at the end and press
enter and this will show you the
specific permissions that this user has
and as you can see it has Grant select
insert delete on the employees database
and then the departments table for that
user so it's very specific you can get
very specific with these privileges now
this next section we'll be diving into
queries and this is where that employees
database will come into effect and I'll
show you guys different types of queries
throughout the demonstration so first
thing we need to do is Select that
database that we want to use so first
off let's show our databases and I just
want to get you guys in the habit of
actually doing this but show databases
semicolon at the end press enter that
will show us all our databases that we
have on the server and what we're
looking for is that employees database
and that's the one we want to select by
using the use command so use and then
the database name so employee and then
let's put a semicolon at the end press
enter and now our database has been
changed to the employees database that's
the one we are currently using now the
core of quering data is the select
statement and it retrieves data from
tables and you can customize what you
want to see now first first off we need
to find out what the tables are in the
database and we can go back to that
command that says show tables and then
semicolon at the end press enter and it
will show us all the tables within the
employees database and now let me show
you guys the basic structure of the
select statement and all we have to do
is type select and then we'll start off
with store which is for everything is
pretty much the wild cord for all
columns within the table and then we
want to specify that table so from a
specific table so we can pick one in
here let's start with the Departments
table and then put a semicolon at the
end press enter and that will list out
all the data within that table and you
can do this for each table within the
database and so let's look up here we
have another table and I'll start with
the employees one as well so there's the
employee table as well so let's run that
select from but instead of selecting the
department let's look at the employees
and let's put a semicolon at the end
press enter and you'll see it'll pull up
a lot of data this table has about
500,000 records within this one table
and that's representative of all the
employees within this organization and
so that select statement will pull
everything with that store wild cord in
there in the select statement now let's
say we want to look at the first 10 rows
of this table well we can limit the
results that are put in front of us by
using the limit Clause within our select
statement so we can go to the end of
this select statement and we can limit
the results to let's say 20 we only want
to see the first 20 records so we can go
down and press enter and this will limit
the results and you'll see that we only
have 20 rows pulled and like I said this
is just a way of limiting it really for
you guys that are watching this video so
you guys can see less data on the screen
now let's work on work on these columns
let's say we only want to see specific
columns so certain data we only need for
whatever we're running this select
statement for and so let's go through
and let's hit the up arrow and I'll be
using the up Arrow a lot and this allows
me to run previous queries but let's say
we don't want to pull all those columns
like I said you can specify specific
columns so let's say we only want to
look at the employee number and the
first name and the last name so we can
type
empore number and then we put a comma
behind it and then first uncore name and
then let's let look at the last name as
well so lastore name and then we can
press enter we don't have to put a comma
after that that is the last column that
we want to pull and also let's change
the limit as well so I can show you guys
the information right on the table so it
doesn't pull in too much too much more
information let's go down hit 10 and
press enter and boom as you can see it
only pulls in those particular columns
that we specified in our select
statement so employee number first name
last name and there you go within the
table so employee number first name last
name boom now one other thing with the
select statement you can pull in this
information in whatever order you want
to and what I mean by that is the
columns let's say we don't want to see
the we want to see the employee ID after
our first name and last name so let's go
back to the end of it put a comma and
let's pull in that employee number and
let's pull it in that order we want to
see first name last name or actually
let's do it a little bit different as
well we can do first name name right
here so let's put a space and go first
underscore name and then put that comma
there and then let's remove the first
name up here at the front and we want to
pull last name first name and then
employee number so let's go on and press
enter and as you can see it'll put it in
that order for us so last name first
name and then employee number at the end
now let's say we want to filter the data
and I don't know how many results will
come up let's say if I select a specific
name so I'm going just select one just
to see and I want to see how many
employees have this same last name so
bam Ford and I know this is a fake name
but there is a way of filtering and this
is using the wear clause in our query so
we can up arrow and then let's go back
in here and put the store let's remove
the columns put the store in there for
the wild cord from employees and then
where we want to type the wear claw in
there so let's take this limit off we
I'm not going to use it I'm going to see
what pulls up but where the last name
underscore and we need to put a equal
sign in it because we're searching for
something specific so we're searching
for the last name to be a specific
variable and so let's put it in quotes
and let's uh paste it in there right
fast I don't think you guys can see that
but bam forward we want to look for
people with the last name of bam for
within the employees table so let's go
on and press enter and see how many
results we get and we get a whole bunch
of results so it's 178 rows that have
that meet criteria and that's
essentially how you filter using the
wear claw and then we can filter this
down even more let's say we want to look
for all the females that have the last
name banford so let's put the up Arrow
up there and then after the banord we
could put another clause which is and so
and the gender equals and thenone want
to specify female so let's put it in a
single quote as well so with a capital f
and boom we are good to go let's see see
what it pulls up and it pulls up
everybody that has the last name of
banford with the gender of female so
that's super cool and then you could
specify that query you know columns if
you want to you can go in here and pull
in the last name and then the first name
and then the gender and then let's go
down and pull in an employee number as
well so and let's go down press enter
and boom it'll pull in just those four
columns that we wanted as well as
searching for that specific criteria so
we got our last name of B of bonford and
then all female employees with all the
columns re requested to see and then you
can modify it you can change this to
let's say male we want to see all the
male employees like that and as you can
see it pulls in you know specifically
males for this these results and it's
103 males versus 75 you know females so
let me show you guys another option you
can run with the select statement and
that is the order buy and first off let
me run a normal select so nor select
store from the employee table and
semicolon at the end press enter and I
will pull in all the information and
what I wanted to do is look at this
column right here this is the actual
hire date of the employee so let's say
we want to order the results by that
hire date and let's look at the oldest
employee up to the newest employee and
so let's run and select again but let's
limit it to just 10 and I'm only doing
that so you guys can see a little
clearer so that shows pretty much the
first 10 records or the first 10 results
and their hire date and like I said I
want to show you guys the order by
clause and so we can type that select
store from employees I'm going to leave
that limit there but the other option is
order by and it's two words and what we
want to order it by is the column so
that's the hire date so let type
hore dates and and press enter and as
you can see it'll pull up the oldest
dates and so that's
1985 January 1st and it goes up from
there so these are our oldest employees
and the reason we know it's going up
because the next employee on a different
date that was hired is January 14th so
1985 so it'll go up from there and I
don't want to I just want to limit the
results so you guys can kind of see it
in that order and you can order it by a
specific column A lot of times you want
to look for that and then also so you
can do the exact same thing for this
this is another date column but there is
a birth date and so we can change that
up and not use the higher date but
instead of that let's look at the birth
dates and this could be for let's say HR
purposes or something to that effect
let's say you want to look at the birth
date of all your employees for whatever
reason you can order you know all the
results by those dates and then you can
also throw your filtering in there with
the wear claw so go on press enter boom
and as you can see that's our oldest
employee right there or a couple of our
oldest employees right here that have
the same birth date which is February
1st of 195 is what what's that about six
employees that have that same birth date
and so this is a good reason to show you
guys another way of filtering by using
that wear clause and let's say we were
looking for all the people with a birth
date but in just the year of 1950 so we
can go through and just search for
specific people with a birth date of of
1952 and let me show you guys that break
out this order by let's remove it and
let's use our wear claw so let's go wear
the birth dates uncore and there's
another clause in there you can put and
that's like and this allows you to
search for text that match but also have
different things either in front of it
or behind it and what we're looking for
is that year two and so we have to put
it in single quotes so single quotes and
then there is a wild cord of the percent
sign so anything before which it doesn't
have anything before we really don't
need to put that there I just wanted to
put it there so you guys can see but's
say it put that wild cord at the end of
it so anything after that as well and
then the quotes at the end of it to
close it out and let's go on and press
enter boom and that'll pull in all the
employees with a birth date in within
two now let's explore how to add data to
a table and first off let's show the
tables again right fast so let's go show
tables semicolon press enter and what I
want to do is look at the Departments
table cuz that's the easiest one to work
with when it comes to inserting data and
let's run a select on the Departments
table right fast select store from
departments and then semicolon at the
end press enter as you can see we only
have a couple records so nine rows so
let's say we want to add a new
Department well to insert new data we
have to use the insert into statement
and so let me give you guys a quick
example we can run through and type
inserts into and then we want to insert
it into the department table and then
now we have to specify our columns so we
have the department number and the
department name so we need to put
parentheses in here and this is to
specify our columns so let's start off
with the first one so department so
dtore number and then put a comma after
that and then a space and then the
department name so D
_ name and now that we have our columns
selected where we want to insert data we
have to type in the values that we want
to put into each one of those columns
for this new Ro that we're adding so
values and then we have to put it in the
same order as they're represented up
here so our department number and
Department name and we just put those
values and we have to put them in a
single quote so let's put the first one
in which is our department number and as
you you can see the next number is
Department 10 so let's put D 010 and
that's Department 10 and I know you guys
can't tell but it's out of order but
Department 9 is the highest one so I
want to go with Department 10 that's how
I figured that out but let's put a
comment in here now let's add our
department name and let's say this is
the technology department so or
information technology whatever you want
to put in here you want to put it in
quotes again sorry about that I didn't
put the quote in but put it in quotes
and then close out our parentheses
anything you open you need to close and
we close out that parenthesis and then
put semicolon at the end and this will
insert that data into the Departments
table so let's go on and press enter
boom query okay one row affected and now
let's select from that department table
again and you guys should see our new
row which is our technology R so D 0000
and that's thep the technology
department now let's say we made a
mistake while inserting that data into
it well we can use another statement
which is a update statement which will
allow you to make changes to any of the
data within the table and when you're
building out this query you want to make
sure you find some form of a unique
identifier that's why majority of tables
will have a primary key or some type of
number that identifies that role
especially if you don't want duplicates
within the table and so our unique
identifier is the deportment number
because that's different per row that's
in the table and so we'll use that as
our wear Clause when we type out our
update query so let's go on and break
this out so let's type updates and what
we want to update is something in our
departments table so update department
and let's say we want to change the
technology to help Des so we have to
type set and then Department name or the
column that we're looking for which is
that department name that we're changing
so Deport uncore name and we want it to
be so we can do equals and we put it in
single quotes so let's say we want to
change that to help Des so the help desk
Department if you you know I'm just
coming up with something but we need
that unique identifier so where
department number equals and we can put
this in single quotes this is just
basically to search for it but the
d010 and then let's close it out with
semicolon and then updates that
department name where the department
number is the 010 so scroll on and press
enter and that should make changes to it
so as you can see right there it says
rows matched and then rows changed and
no warnings as long as we don't see any
warnings or errors we get to go so let's
go down and select from that table again
and as you can see we have a help desk
department now and that's
d010 now let's say we want to delete
that row that help Des row we just
created so there is a statement you can
run and that is the delete statement so
let's go on and type this out so delete
and then we want to delete from the
Department table so we have to type that
out and then where the department and I
already know what to use I'm going to
use department number because that's our
unique identifier and plus it's super
short and specific as far as the
department number and there's no other
number like that so you can't make a
mistake but department number equals and
we use that exact same format so single
quotes and then
d010 and then put a semicolon at the end
but that will delete that Row from the
table so boom and as you see query okay
and then we can go back in select from
the Departments and you'll see that help
desk is gone I know it's kind of hard to
see because it's not ordered properly
but yeah help desk is gone from this
table so the next thing I want to cover
is primary keys and foreign Keys now
first off let me explain what a primary
key is a primary key in my SQL is like a
special idid for each row within the
table it's a unique number or code that
helps you identify and organize the data
so if you think about it it's just like
your fingerprint is unique to you a
primary key ensures that each row within
a table is different from the others and
this makes it easier to find and manage
information within a database and let me
start off by showing you guys a primary
key right fast which I showed you one
earlier in the video when we created our
first table but let's show you the
primary key within one of the tables
within this employees database that
we're looking at now so let's start off
with the employees one by running the
describe command and this will basically
give you the information about a
particular table and let's type employee
and then semicolon at the end press
enter and like I said this will give you
all the information about this table and
as you can see right here under key this
column right here it says Prime that
stands for prime primary so our employee
number is our primary key and typically
the data type is integer and it's and
pretty much a primary key is unique so
this number is different for each row
within the table now let's talk talk
about a foreign key and a foreign key is
like a bridge between two tables it
helps one table understand information
from another table so for instance this
employees table and let's say the
Department's table well a foreign key in
the employees table links to the
Department's table showing which
department each employee belongs to and
it's like a connection that keeps data
organized and related between tables and
what I want to do is create a foreign
key using both of those tables and let's
describe the Departments table right
fast so you guys can see the information
about that table as well and departments
and then semic and press enter and it'll
describe that table as well and as you
can see the primary key is is the
department number and so what we want to
do is add the department key which is
that primary key or the department
number to this table and that way we can
have a foreign key or a foreign
connection between the department as
well as the employees so each employee
will know what department they work for
and so this is a great example and the
first thing we need to do is add another
column here because you can't use a
column any of the columns that are
already there cuz they already have data
in it so you need to add another col
colum to this table and what I typically
do when I'm adding a foreign key I'll
use the same field name that way you
don't get confused with it and so let's
go down and alter this table so alter
table and then we want to alter the
employees table and what we want to do
is add a column and I haven't showed you
guys this yet but add column and then
what we want to do is specify the column
name so we want to add
department number and then we have to
tell the character type and that's why I
described this table as well the
apartment's table the apartment number
is Char so characters and four
characters so let's go down and put the
exact same thing so chore and then in
parentheses we can put the number four
in there so four characters and let's go
down and put a semicolon at the end of
it and this will alter that table boom
and we're good to go so query okay you
know zero rows affected and then let's
describe our employees table again let's
go back in here and look at describe
employee
boom as you can see we have a new column
in there it's that deportment numbers it
has that same data type which is TR 4
and I put in there uh yes I left it yes
as it could be no and the default is no
and now let's go down and alter our
employees table in order to make that a
foreign key and so let's walk through
this we can type alter and then table
and then the employee table and what we
need to do is add a constraint and you
can name the actual foreign key and
that's what this line actually means so
add constraint and let's name our
foreign key let's name it uh foreign key
let's see uncore departments underscore
number and so I just give it something
unique forign key so that FK and then
underscore deportment number that's the
name of our constraint and then let's
press enter and then let's add our
foreign key so let's go foreign key and
then we have to specify that column
within our table our employee table and
that is the department uncore number and
let's go down and close that out press
enter and then we have to reference our
forign key so the reference is going to
be in our deportment table so we have to
type references and then deportment and
then specify that column as well which
is basically the same so department
uncore number and let's go down and
close that out and then we put our CA
colon at the end and let's press enter
and it should add our forign key and as
you can see that kind of took a little
while it was about 53 seconds that it
took almost a minute minute because of
the 300,000 rows that it has to go
through and basically it's just updating
that column and marking it as a foreign
key location now let's go to and run a
quick select right fast so you guys can
see that column in action so select
store from our employee table and let's
limit it to 10 cuz I don't want to see
all those rows let's go on press enter
boom and as you can see we have that
department number column and then also
let's describe that table as well so
let's go in here and look at our
employees table again under the describe
and as you can see it is a foreign key
and just to explain what this means
right here it says Ma so that basically
means multiple and this is our foreign
key so that means that multiple
occurrences of a given value are
permitted within that column so that's
essentially what that means now next
I'll run a quick query and this is a
update query it'll actually take me a
while to actually run this because I'll
do a update and what I'm doing is
grabbing random deportment IDs and
dropping it into our employees table
under that new department number column
and this is so I can next show you guys
how to work with joins so you can follow
along if you want to if you don't this
will take some time depending on the
resources on your server because it has
to go through 300,000 rows and update
them so what I want to do is update the
employee and what we want to do is set
that appartment number within that table
and we want it to equal some information
that we select basically and this is
basically a nested query so to speak so
I'm going to just throw this in there
and that's to open up the parentheses
for the other query and what I'm doing
is a select and then we want to select
that deportment number and what we want
to select it from is the Departments
table so let's press enter from
Department table and we want to order it
because there's other options like I
said I didn't go too deep into a lot of
these options but there are plenty of
options out there I didn't want to it'll
take me all day to go through all the
options that you could do within a
select query I just wanted to show you
the base level and then you can build
from there by looking at the
documentation and what I want to do is
use a variable that's built into my SQL
which is called random and so r a n d
and then we put the parentheses at the
end of it it'll basically pull random
deportment numbers for each row within
this table and so let's type a limit in
there and we want a limit to one and
then let's close out our top parentheses
up here anything you open you must close
so close that parentheses and then put
our semicolon at the end and like I said
this is going to take some time and if
you want to just pause the video that
way you can copy this and that way you
can run this query as well to update
your employees table with a random
deportment number so let's go on and
press enter and like I said this is
going to run for a little while and I'll
be back and it should tell you at the
end of it how long it took me and let's
compare times be right back all right
cool so that wasn't too long it was uh
35 seconds so 35.2 eight let me know if
you beat my time down in the comments
but it updated each one of those rows
with a random department number and
let's verify this by selecting store
from our employee table and semic
calling at the end press enter and it'll
give us our results and as you can see
it has a random department number
throughout the whole table and so
that'll allow me to show you guys joints
now one other thing I did was I went
back and ran another query that'll
change some of the department numbers to
null so that way the inner joins and the
left joins and all that stuff will show
properly so you guys can get a good
example of how they work and so let's
start off by explaining what a joint is
it's like bringing two tables together
to find related information and there
are three types types of joins and the
first joint I want to show you guys is a
in joint and it shows only common data
between both tables for example if we
join that employees table and the
Department's table using the department
number which is our foreign key within
that employees table we'll get a list of
employees belonging to specific
departments and so it'll exclude all the
rols that have null in in it it doesn't
have a specific Department in it and
let's go on and run a enter join right
fast and let's type select and I'll put
this stuff on multiple lines so select
store from employee and then what we
want to do is a inner join between two
different tables and the other table is
our department table because they both
have something in common which is that
department ID and so we have to specify
that so hit on type on and this is
basically a injin in departments on
these specific column so let's type
employees first which is our first table
and we want to match our Department's
number column within this table so let's
make sure I type it in correctly so
Department no and then we want to make
sure it equals the department and then
department uncore number and then let's
close out our query and press enter and
this will give you a good clear picture
of what it actually does so what it'll
do is it'll bring in all the information
from both tables so we got our employee
the ID we have that date of birth we
have that first name last name and then
their gender and then their hire date
and then we also have that employee ID
and we have it twice and this is the one
represented within our employees table
and then this one right here is the
representation of the one in our
department table and then ourselves so
that's considered a inner joint and
basically it's joining on those two
columns just matching them up and one
other thing I want to point out as you
can see the row amount it's actually
300,000 rows within there but some of
them are set to null or they have null
within that department ID and so they're
excluded and so that's what makes the
difference between a inner join and a
left join and a right join the inner
join will only bring in roles that match
100% so if this doesn't have a
department ID it will exclude it from
the results and let's run this query
again right fast and let me show you
something a little bit different so
we're going to run a enter join again
and this applies to all the different
types of joins a left join and a right
join as well you can select specific
columns and so let's say we only want to
see the employee number so let's put
that there and then the first name as
well as our last name and then the
department that they work for so this is
from that other table that is joined so
let's type department and then
underscore name so we want to see their
employee ID or employee number their
first name last name and then the
department that they work for and we
don't have to put a comma at the end of
it and let's go on and press enter and
that should pull in just that
information that we requested and as you
can see you don't have to see that
department ID you can just see the
department name and that's a great way
of organizing the results and using a
join to bring in information from other
tables now a left join this type shows
all the data from the left table which
is our employees table and only matching
data from the right table so it'll list
all the employees and their departments
if they're available so this is where
we'll bring in those NS because certain
records won't have a department ID but
it'll still bring in those employees and
it'll just show null next to it so let's
go on and do a left join right fast and
all I'm going to do is go over here I'm
going leave everything the same and
we're going to type left here and like I
said it's going to pull everything from
the employees table and it's all based
on that department number you know all
that good stuff so let's go down and run
it again and you'll see that it'll pull
in all the records and then you'll start
seeing all the NS in there so this will
bring in all our employees and it'll
also show you the ones that have an
employee ID associated with it it'll
show that employee name as well and then
n for the ones that don't have one so
that's what a left join will do it'll
basically bring in all the records from
the left table and then the information
that's related from the other table
instead of excluding all the NS or the
exact matches and then the right join is
the exact opposite it'll basically
display all the data from the right
table and the matching data from the
left table and this will give you a list
of all departments and their employees
if any and so this right join it may
look a little weird let's see let's
actually see what happens but let's go
right and this may not work too well
well and this is based on my mind just
thinking through what it will actually
show so let's go through and look at it
right fast and it's it kind of looks
like that inner join because it'll only
bring in records from that table that
match so that right join won't really
work for this example but you can see it
actually works it works it pulls in only
those that match the right table which
excludes all the dos and so that's
pretty much how to use joins in my squel
all right so let me show you a little
bit more Advan
of a view and I'll just kind of type
this one out so you guys can see but
first let me explain exactly what I'm
trying to do so if we select our
departments table so select store from
department and then semic colon at the
end press Center boom let's say we want
to add into this table the amount of
employees that are in each department
and so you could do this or accomplish
this by using a joint and essentially
what we'll be adding is another column
here from our employees table that will
count the amount of employees that fall
under each one of these departments and
so me go on to show you guys how to do
this right fast and we can type select
and then
department.
department number and this is a way to
drill down to all of the columns that we
want to use within this table we can
specify it by putting the table as well
as the column and so sometimes you have
to do this because if you leave it kind
of generic especially when some of these
tables have the same column title you
have to kind of specify it like for
instance the employees table does have
that department number column in it so
you want to specify it and then let's do
Department table again and then we want
to get that department name and we need
to put that underscore in there and then
now we'll use a built-in variable in
order to create our third column here
and what we want to do is count and you
have to put the information within par
parentheses that you're trying to do as
far as the variable what it's actually
doing so we want to count the employees
table and then the employee number
column so
empore number and now we want to
continue out our join so as number and
this is what we want to name it so we
we're naming this column as num of
employees so we type that in and then we
want to catch that from the Departments
table so boom and now let's build out
our join so let's do a left join and
that way it'll pull everything from the
Department's table and then all the
information that matches within the
employees table so let's go employee and
then on and then we specify what we need
to match and then that is the
department. department number and then
we want that to equal our employee table
and then that department number that we
have in there soore number and now let's
add a little more in here let's Group by
Department's number and then departments
and that is the department name that we
want to do so we want to group it by
that so let's go on and close it out
this query should run perfectly as long
as I didn't type it in incorrectly or
type anything incorrectly but we can go
back and check if we need to so let's go
on and press enter see what happens and
yes it worked correct so we got our
department number we got our department
name and this is pulling the number of
employees from the employee table that
fall under each one of these departments
and I kind of just wanted to show you
guys something a little bit more complex
and what you can actually do with these
joins all right so let's talk about
views in my SQL and Views are like a
saved query that you can use to simplify
your data retrieval and it's essentially
a virtual table created from one or more
existing tables it doesn't store data
itself and so views allow you to see
specific data from your table without
altering the original data and one thing
about of you is it's constantly updated
and it's all based on the data in those
original tables so if you delete data in
a specific table that's associated with
a view the next time you run that view
it will show you the updated information
for that table and it's all based on how
you run the query within the view and so
let me go down and show you guys a quick
example right fast and let's just start
with the basic syntax and that is create
View and like I said I've said
throughout this whole course that these
queries sound like sentences so we want
to create a view and we want to name
that view so we want to name it whatever
we want to name it so I'm going to name
this one
employee gender because I want this view
to be specific to the genders of the
employees within the table and then we
have to type as because this is the
query we want to run every time we run
this View and so let's type select and
then let's look at the first name so of
that employees table and then and the
last name of that employees table and
then also the gender and then let's
press enter and then we want to specify
what we want this information pulled
from which is the employees table let's
put a semicolon at the end to close out
our query press enter and it will create
our view long as you don't see an error
that mean the query was okay it ran
successfully it created that view now
let's run show tables that way we can
see the actual View and it looks as
though it's a table and I'll show you
guys that second so show tables and
press enter and as you can see we got
our employees gender view there now it
doesn't put anything next to it or it
doesn't show in any way that it's a view
the only way you can kind of see it is
if you're in let's say MySQL workbench
you'll see it'll show up under a
different section when you're connected
to the database but we know that it's a
view and so you can interact with this
just like any table and so let's go on
in and type in our select statement and
store from and then let's select that
view so employee uncore gender then see
me coling at the end press enter boom
and that's our view and it'll pull in
all the data and it's all based on what
you put within that query for the view
and it'll always show that information
the exact same way and then let's say
one of these employees is removed from
the original table then it will update
this view automatically you don't have
to update in two different places like
update in the original table and then
update Within the view the view will
automatically update based on the
original table and data so let me show
you guys how to drop that view so let's
run show tables again and it's
essentially like dropping a table so
let's go show tables and then all you
have to do is type drop View and since
we know that's a view you know tables
won't work so if you if you type drop
table that won't work we have to drop
view because we know it's a view so drop
view then
employee gender and then semicolon at
the end press enter that'll drop that
view for us so we don't we won't see it
anymore now let me give you guys another
example and we'll look at a different
table because I don't like using that
employees table because of amount of
data that's in it let's focus in on the
Departments table and let's just run
select right fast store from department
and then semicolon at the end press
enter boom and as you can see that's all
the data within there let's say let's
add a column to this table and you guys
remember the alter table command so
let's type alter table and then
department and then let's add a colum so
add column and then let's create a email
column and let me tell you how this
makes sense so let's say each department
has an email address that's associated
with that department and typically what
that's called is a distribution list so
each department will have a distribution
list and so when someone sends an email
to that distribution list it will send
send a email to all the employees that
work for that department and so that's
the concept behind what I'm doing so
let's add the column and let's call it
emails and then let's specify the type
of data to be stored in that column so
let's go vure and then let's give it
about 50 characters cuz like I said it's
it's a email address so it probably
shouldn't be that long you know what I'm
saying so 50 characters should work so
let's go and press enter boom that'll go
down in create that column for us and
then we can at the tables again the
deportment table and press enter and as
you can see we have that column now and
so let's add some data to this column
and I'm building this out you'll see
once we get to the view section what I'm
actually doing and so let's update the
data by adding a email address for each
one of the Departments so let's go
update the Departments table and let's
set our email for the first one which is
marketing to equal and we can put those
single quotes in there that way it'll
add that information in there for us and
let's go with marketing atcom and so
that's our distribution email address
and then we have to run a where in so we
can specify where that needs to go cuz
right now it doesn't know where to put
that information and we want to put that
under the marketing department email
address so we could go where department
number equals and then we want to search
for one so d001 and we know that that is
the marketing role and so let's put a
semicolon at the end and press enter and
that should update that Row for us and
let's just run a quick select all right
fast select from departments boom and as
you can see we got our email address in
there for the marketing department and
so I won't bore you guys with watching
me do this I'm basically going to run
the last command multiple times just
updating and adding an email address for
each one of them so I'll be back when
this finishes all right cool so I
updated the table let's go go on and run
a select again so select store from
department and press enter and as you
can see we have an email address or a
distribution email address for each one
of the Departments within our
organization now let's go down and
create another view so let's type create
View and then we want to call this view
deportment email so that's our
department email and we want to set our
query as and let's go on and type it out
but let's type our select and then let's
pull in just two columns within here and
let's look at the Departments uncore
number and then also let's look at the
email and then we want to do this from
our Department's table boom and press
enter and it'll run that query it'll
create that view and so let's go show
and then you'll see that we have our
department email view there and let's go
down and select that view right fast so
select store from Department _ email and
semicolon press enter and that is our
view that we created now here is the
full example so let's go into let's
actually inser insert some more data
into our departments tables like a new
Department similar to what we did
earlier as far as adding let's say a
help test department so let's gooll on
and write out a quick query to insert
into department and this will add us
some data in there so department and
then specify those columns that we want
to update or input data in we have to
put those in parentheses so departments
uncore number and then departments
uncore name and then we want to use our
new column which is that email column so
let going to close out our parentheses
and then let's type in the values so
values and then let's put those in
quotes so let's create a new department
number Department 10 so 0 one 0 Let's
close out those quotes and then let's
name let's give it a department name so
our department name is help Des we'll
just use that same one we used for so
help des and then the email address is
we can name it let's say help and also
let's make sure we add our quotes I
don't want to forget that so let's put
our quotes in there and then let's put
our quotes for our email address as well
so let's name it help at
abc.com close out our quotes close out
our parentheses and then put our
semicolon at the end of it and press
enter and cool so we added that new line
in there and let's run a select of our
just the normal table so from
departments and just to show you guys
that the information has been updated so
help des and then it we added in that
email address for the help Des
department or that distribution list and
then as you can see this is our view so
we updated it just in our Department's
table and so with our view I'm going
just run this same select query for our
department email View and you'll see
that it'll update based on what's in the
original table so we don't have to
updated in two places that's the whole
purpose of me showing you guys this
exercise so as you can see we got the
help Des change that we made to the
original departments table so hopefully
that gives you a better understanding of
how views work and it's the same way
let's say we removed that column out of
there it will update our view as well
all right so the next thing I want to
cover is indexes and a index is
basically a quick reference for your
database and it helps speed up data
retrieval it's a structure that
organizes data in a way that makes
searching for specific information much
faster so think of it as a index in a
book that tells you where to find a
particular topic without reading the
whole book so let's go through a few
examples right fast and first off let me
show you guys how to see the indexes
that are currently there for a
particular table and what I want to do
is look at our employees table so all we
have to do is type show indexes and then
from from a specific table which we will
look at the employee table and just put
a semicolon at the end press enter and
this will show you all the indexes and
there currently are two indexes on the
employees table currently and the first
one is associated with the primary key
and the second one is the foreign key
but let's say with this table we do a
lot of searches by last name well we
could create a index to structure and
organize that data to make it searchable
a whole lot faster and so let me give
you an example of creating that index
and all you have to do is type create
index and then you want to name that
index and what I typically do or the
format I do X and whatever column I'm
working with so last name is what we
want to search so or what we typically
search a lot and then now we have to
specify the actual column within the
table we have to specify the table and
then the column so all we have to do is
type on our table which is that employee
table and then we have to specify the
column and we put that in parth pares so
we can go back in here and type our
column name which is last name and then
put a semicolon at the end press enter
and that will create our index it takes
some time depending on how big the data
is cuz it has to structure it but as you
can see that query ran successfully and
it created our index now let's go back
and run these show indexes for employee
and let's see our new index that's in
there and as you can see it's the idx
last name that's the name that we gave
it and then it looks at that last name
column within the table and so let's
just run a quick query right fast and
you guys may or may not see a difference
when we last ran the select on the
employees table because it's all
dependent on the amount of data that's
in the database whether this will
benefit you or not and then how often
this information is updated as well as
searched so let's type store and then
from employee and let's put a wear
clause in there so wear last name equals
and let's look for a employee last name
of bass I know that's one of the names
in there so let's type ba a a z and then
close that out and then semicolon at the
end press enter and as you can see it
took no time to actually find that it
was less than a second to actually pull
all the data for a bass and that's what
it'll do it'll increase that speed on
searching within that based on the
column that you specify in your index
and so let's remember that so it only to
it took less than a second to actually
search for all the employees with the
last name of baz and so let's drop that
index and this is a good opportunity for
me to show you guys how to do that and
essentially all you have to do is type
alter table employee and then we want to
drop our index and then we have to
specify that name so id id X and
underscore last name and it'll drop that
index for us so let's go on put a
semicolon at the end press enter that'll
drop that index and then now let's run
run that same select where we search for
the last name of bass and press enter
and it took 10 seconds so you'll see you
know a difference depending on how much
data it is within that table and so
there are some downsides to using a
index for instance there are slower
rights so let's say this table is
updated a lot then it slows down the
insertion or the updates and the
deletion operations because they must be
maintained alongside the data and I mean
the indexes they have to be maintained
and then also there may be an issue with
storage because these indexes they
consume extra disc space and so if the
database is super large then those
resources could be significant and also
the complexity of these indexes you know
what I'm saying they require regular
maintenance and then also like one of
the other cons so to speak of using
indexes is the memory usage it does use
a lot of memory and that can affect
effect these servers performance so you
have to think about that when creating
these indexes and be very strategic all
right so next I want to talk about
subqueries and a subquery is basically a
query within a query and it's a way to
retrieve data from one table based on
the results of another query and for
example you can use a subquery to find
employees in a specific Department by
first querying the department and then
using the results to search the
employees table so let's go through a
demonstration right fast and I actually
wrote out a query for this and I'll show
you guys that demonstration now and
let's just type select and then store
from our employees table and so this is
our main query this is the main query
that we want to use and I'll show you
guys the subquery in a second but I'll
use it under the wear Clause within this
query so let's go select store from
employees and then where department
number equals and this is where we we
will put our subqueries and we have to
put our subquery in parentheses cuz it's
a totally separate query and then let's
type another select and then department
number and then what I'll do is pull
this information from another table
which is that Department's table so so
let's talk that in department and then
where Department name equals sales let's
look for the sales department and let's
put that in quotes single quotes and
then let's close out our query and it
should work for us so let's press enter
both as you can see it pulls in all the
people from sales so that's super dope
right it goes through and searches and
finds all those people with the
Department name of sales and it's all
based on the department number so that's
essentially a subquery example and I
only wanted to cover like one example
because subqueries can be get very
complex well queries in general can get
very complex and then when you start
adding subqueries into the mix it takes
a little time to build out those queries
queries and so I want you guys to
practice writing out queries as well as
subqueries based on documentation that
you look out there for my SQL or SQL
queries all right so next I wanted to
cover store procedures now store
procedures are like a reusable script
that contains a series of SQL statements
and it's like creating a custom function
that allows you to perform specific
tasks especially if they're repeatable
for instance if you guys remember the
query we ran during the join ction and
I'll actually paste it in here so you
guys can see but this is the select
statement that we created in order to
pull the count of employees based on the
Departments and so let's go down and run
it right fast so you guys can get a
picture of what what I'm saying so
department number Department name and
then the amount of employees that are in
each one of these departments and so
let's say we had to type this out a
whole bunch of times you know this is
something that we reuse all the time
like every day or so well it'll be a
pain to have to retype this every single
time so we can create what is called a
store procedure with this query built
into it and so let me give you example
of how to actually do that so the first
thing let me show you guys something
right fast so if we type select store
from departments and I'm just showing
you a basic query so you can understand
what I'm going to show you so at the end
of each SQL statement or query you have
to put what they call a delimiter and
the delimiter by default is the
semicolon within SQL but within our
store procedure while we creating that
procedure we have to put this query in
the middle of another query and so in
order to end the creation of the store
procedure we have to change that
delimiter so it doesn't mess up our
actual query that we're going to put in
the inside of it and so I'm not going to
run this query let's go on and back it
off but I'm going to show you guys how
to change the delimiter and all you have
to do is type delimiter and then we can
specify what that delimiter is most
people use these slashes that's
typically what you'll see in
documentation but there's others you can
use but I'll just use the slashes so
four slashes let's press enter and that
will change our delimiter for ending a
SQL statement now let's go on and type
out our store procedure and the way you
create it is simply create and then we
want to create a procedure and then we
want to name that procedure so I'll just
name it
employee accountor by department so
department and then at the end of the
name of the procedure we have to put C's
and so this is essentially like a custom
function so after this we have to
continue writing but we have to specify
the beginning of our query that we want
to run within our store procedure so by
specifying you have to type begin and
this is just a designator to let SQL
know that this is the beginning of the
script and so let's press enter and then
let's paste our query in there boom and
and right now if we didn't go in and
change our delimiter when I press enter
it's going to to finish out this this
whole statement that we wrote out which
we did don't want it to do that's why we
changed the delimiters so just like we
put the begin here of where our select
statement starts we have to put an end
so if we didn't change that delimiter we
wouldn't be able to end the statement so
let's press enter now and as you can see
it didn't complete out our SQL statement
and so let's go down to type in and then
our slashes and that will allow us to
end this statement that we wrote so
let's go on and press enter as you can
see query Okay so it ran successfully it
created our procedure now let's go on
and change our delimiter back you don't
want to forget to do this otherwise
you're going to be running other queries
and you'll be like what why is it not
running properly and that's because the
delimiter hasn't been changed back so
let's type delimiter and then the
semicolon like what is typically used
for our queries press enter and that'll
change our delimiter back to that
semicolon now let me show you guys how
to call that store procedure that we
have cuz it will use this name right
here so employee counts department so
I'm going to copy it right fast and then
all you have to do is type call and it's
like calling a function so call and then
the procedure name and then let's go to
put the semicolon at the end and press
enter and that will run that query for
us and so that's a great way of running
complex queries you know that you have
to use multiple times or you run daily
or multiple times a day this is a great
way of running those queries by creating
a store procedure and then you can call
it store procedure and plus it's less
text you have to type and so lastly let
me show you guys how to drop that store
procedure so all we have to do is type
drop and this will basically remove the
procedure so procedure and then the
procedure name and I'm going to paste it
in here but you don't need these uh
parentheses at the end of it that's
mainly just for the function or calling
it and then when you create it you have
to put those parentheses there but all
it is is a name so you want to just drop
that procedure by its name without the
parentheses so let's go on and press
enter that will drop that story
procedure and as you can see if we call
it again it'll say error because it does
not exist anymore we deleted it all
right so the next important thing I want
to show you guys in my squel is triggers
and triggers is like a set of predefined
actions that automatically occur when
specific events take place within your
database and this could be things such
as inserting or updating
or even deleting data and so let me go
down and show you guys a quick example
and I have to go through a couple
processes one of the first thing I want
first things I want to do is create a
new table I want to show you guys how to
create a audit log and basically the
purpose of this is every time we make an
update to the employees table I want
this information tracked within another
table and so let's start off by creating
that table so we can type create table
and then let's name this employee Audits
and then let's put our information for
the table in there let's start off with
a audit ID boom and then we can make
this Sager so int and then let's make
this Auto increment so
autocore increment and this is basically
to auton number each row within our
table and then let's make this the
primary key boom and then let's put a
comma there and let's create our next
column and let's start with the
department number because I want to do
this based on the department so let's
say and this is the only example I could
think of to show you guys a trigger so
let's say an employee is assigned to a
different department and we need to
update and let's say we want to track
those changes well we'll put this in
here so it can track the new department
for that user and then this will be at
integer and press comma and let's get
the next step so let's go with our
action so this is the actual action of
what happens as far as the type of query
that's running and like I said I want to
show you guys after an update so let's
go action and then vour and let's make
the number of characters around 50 boom
just go on put a commment there and then
lastly Let's uh put the action dates so
this will track the actual time that
this change happened within that table
and then we can set the type to time
stamp that's a good one to actually use
and let's press enter and then close out
our parentheses as well as the semicolon
press enter and that should create our
table for us and let's go with a select
right fast just to check it out so
select store from our employee _ audit
table and let's close it out with the
semicolon press enter and it won't show
anything cuz there's no data in there
yet but our table is created so now
let's go on and create our trigger and
we have to change our delimiter again
because of the way I'm writing this
trigger so let's change it to our for
slashes again and press enter and the
way you create a trigger is as follows
so so create trigger and then let's name
our trigger so we can call this employee
uncore Audits and then underscore we can
just specify that it is a trigger and
let's go on and type out the details of
our trigger so after an update on the
employee table and then for each row
enter and then this will be the
beginning of our statement so let's type
begin and press enter and then let's do
our insert into our employ employee
audit table and then we want to update
specific columns within that table so
let's start off with the department
number and then the action we want to
update the action column as well as our
action date and let's close out those
parentheses and now let's type in our
values so values and there's a built-in
way of looking at the change like you
can type new and this will show you the
new information that's being inserted
into the table or you can also look at
old which is the current data that's
there but we want to look at the new
data we just want to track that new data
that's being inserted into the table so
new and then it's coming from the
Departments number and then also let's
say we want to just we know this is a
update trigger so let's say we only want
to put text in there that just says
update so we can specify you know
specific text within a column so we
could just put updates so each one of
the triggers that will happen it will
put update in there and that's a way of
tracking our updates then also the
action date we can use a built-in
variable which is now and I'm going to
type it in all cap so you guys can
understand it but it's just a built-in
function that you can use and that will
bring the current time and date and put
that into our field so let's close out
our main parentheses and then let's go
down and put our semicolon at the end CU
that'll end out our insert query and
let's press enter and just like we had
to type begin we have to type in that
was the whole purpose of changing our
delimiter so let's type in then our
delimiter that we have currently set
which is the for slash4 slash so let's
go and press enter boom so that took and
that created our trigger now let's
change our delimiter back right fast and
we want to change it back to our
semicolon so when we run our following
queries they'll work properly and so let
me show you guys how to show the
triggers so so it's a very simple
command all you have to do is type show
triggers with an S put semicolon at the
end and this will show all our triggers
right there as you can see that is our
trigger that we just created so the
employee audit trigger and it gives you
all the information about the actual
trigger and if you have other triggers
they'll be listed here as well so now
let's find some information to update so
let's type select and let's just select
some information from our employees
table so let's type that in semicolon at
the end press enter and maybe I should
have did it this way let's throw in the
limits after that so we can just pull up
the top 10 records that will be
displayed so this is a easy way of
finding something to update so let's say
we want to update this first line and
it's all based on the department number
like I said once you update the
department number it will track that in
our audit table so let's go on and run a
update query so let's type updates and
then employee table and then let's set
our department number because that's
what set Sofi trigger so department
number and then let's change the
department number to let's say Georgie
forcillo works for the help Des
department so let's go and throw the
help Des ID in there department number
in there so it's 010 and then close that
out and then now let's do our wear
Clause so wear employee number equals
and let's go to and grab their employee
number right fast and drop that in there
and put our semicolon at the end and
let's go to and run our update query and
looks like we have an issue hold on
let's see and I believe I made a mistake
when I created the table so this is a
good way of showing you guys how to
alter the table right fast and let's
describe our employees table and I just
want to see what the character is set
for and yeah it looks like I made the
wrong setup for the audit table that we
created and yeah we can look at that
right there just by describing this
table as well so it's our audit table so
employee Audits and let's check this out
and it looks like yeah I put the
department number as an integer when it
should be character for so that's the
mistake I made and so I'm glad this
actually happened so I can show you guys
how to fix issues like this or track
them down because as you can see this
error it just kind of gives you it gives
you information you know don't get me
wrong it gives you information but a lot
of times you got to dig sometimes the
errors are vague and you got to kind of
dig through where the issue lies and so
let's alter that table right fast that
employees audit let's go right here just
type in the front so alter table and
then employees audits let's delete that
off and then let's modify a column and
this is changing the type so all we have
to do is specify that column which is
our department uncore number and then we
can specify what we want to change it to
and so that's why I described this so I
could just typeing in you know properly
so Char and then put four right here and
let's put the semicolon at the end
and move the mouse out the way so you
guys can see but this will alter our
table and now let's describe it again
and that way we could see the changes
and boom we are good to go so let's go
on and make our changes in our employees
table again so let's scroll up and let's
see where we can find that change yeah
this is the change we want to make so
update employee set department number to
d010 where employee number is 10,000 so
let's press enter and we shouldn't run
into that area yeah we don't so let's
select our our employees audit table so
select store from
employee audit so you guys can see the
information that's presented to that
table and that lets us know our trigger
actually worked and as you can see it
pulls in the department number the new
department number and see this is just a
basic understanding or basic concept of
setting this up you can set up Tri
triggers that are way more complex like
for instance you can track the old data
as well as the new data you can create
more columns in here and that's
typically how you'll see it in a
production environment it'll track old
and new changes that way you can correct
those changes if need be by looking
through the Audits and now let me show
you guys a little bit more of this audit
log or this trigger in action like a
while back I created a query that would
go in and randomly insert departments
within all of the users within the
employees table and so let's run that
again so you guys can see the rows that
are inserted throughout this table and I
know it'll populate this audit there'll
be a whole bunch of changes or updates
within this table but I just want to
show you guys how these triggers
actually can be very beneficial so let's
hit paste let's paste it in there and
this is something that I wrote a while
back and I'll just break it down for you
right fast but it's basically going to
update the employees table it's going to
set the department number to equal and
then we have a nested query and this is
basically select the department number
from Department table and then we
ordering it by random so this is a
built-in function and then we can limit
it to one and that will do that for
every rle within the employees table and
so let's go down and press enter and let
this run and then we'll look back at our
audit table up here our employees audit
table once this completes and we'll see
all the Okay cool so our update query
has ran successfully as you can see it
made a couple changes or not a lot of
changes and so let's select our audits
table again and press enter and let's
see all the changes as you can see it's
like 30,000 cuz it went through every
record you know what I'm saying and this
will keep going as you run updates on
that table so let's say you make a lot
of changes depending on the department
it'll list them all here and that way
you can trace back any issues that may
have been made in the table
unintentionally all right so after
showing you guys these store procedures
and triggers I wanted to show you guys
another command within my SQL which is
process list and this is essentially
like a to-do list for the database
server and it keeps track of all the
tasks the server is currently working on
and each task similar to a operating
system is called a process and can
include things like executing queries
handling connections or performing
updates and so let me show you guys this
Command right fast and it's very simple
all you have to do is type show process
list and then semicolon at the end and
this will show you all the process is
currently running on a server as you can
see it breaks everything in columns so
you got your ID you got your user you
got your host the database that's
associated with that user so to speak
the commands the time State you know
information about the server so as you
can see it's pulling in that process
right there show process list that's the
query that I just ran using my root
account so you can see pretty much any
and everything that's going on on the
server and I wanted to let you guys know
this an important command to understand
because it helps you manage all the
processes and then also understand the
performance of the server okay so the
next thing I want to cover is MySQL dump
and MySQL dump is a built-in utility
that's included with mySQL that allows
you to make backups of your entire
database and you can also get very
specific with it and back up just
specific parts of the database as well
and this tool will help you save your
data so you can restore it if something
something goes wrong or let's say you
need to move the database to a different
server that provides more performance
for the amount of data that's included
in it well this allow you to do that as
well and so just to kind of cover it
MySQL dumps it takes all the data and
structure of your database and save it
into a file and it's typically a SQL
file so if you guys remember earlier in
the course I imported that test database
it had the extension of SQL so I'm sure
they created that test database for
others to use using MySQL dump and so
when we get into the examples I want to
show you that it's is like very super
easy to use and you can run it right
from the command line and another thing
you don't have to stop like my SQL in
order to create the backup it'll work
while the database is running and a
super cool part about it it will ensure
that your data's Integrity is maintained
during the backup process and so let's
go through a couple examples right fast
and what I need to do is exit out of my
SQL because like I said it's a separate
utility that comes along with my SQL and
so let's go down and back up that
employees table with all those changes
that we made so let's go with mySQL dump
and then we have to specify a user in
order to connect to our mySQL database
and we want to use our root account and
then we can put- P for our password and
it's similar to how we logged into it
and also I forgot about this we have to
put pseudo in there so we can connect to
the database and now let's do the
employees database and then let's
specify the file that we want to name it
so we have to put the right arrow just
like when we import it we use the left
arrow pointing to the left we need to
use the one that points to the right
because we're grabbing all the data or
the database from within the SQL server
and dumping it to a file and this is the
structure and everything associated with
it it even includes the data that's
within the database and so let's name
name our file EMP and then let's goore
backup and then it will store it in the
current working directory we are in
which is our home directory so that's
fine for now but you can specify another
directory by typing out the full path
we'll just roll with it like this and
press enter and then it'll ask us for
our pseudo password because we had to
type pseudo and then there is no
password for our roote account so let's
press enter and go down and Export or
dump our database and as you can see it
didn't take long at all and so let's LS
our current working directory and you
guys will see the employees back up and
then let's put this in human readable
form so you guys can see the size of the
actual database file so it's 176
megabytes that's how big the actual
database is and let's log back into our
database right fast so P sudo my SQL and
then our user which is roots and then- P
for password press enter and press enter
no password and let's go show databases
and semicolon at the end press enter
it'll show us all our databases so what
I'm going to do is drop the employees
database and we all remember how to drop
a database and all we have to do is type
drop and then the database and then the
database name we're going to drop that
employee database and semicolon at the
end and let's go enter and that will
delete that database and so let's run
these show again right fast and we'll
see that that database is gone and we're
like oh crap made a mistake I did not
mean to delete that database well one
good thing about this we created a
backup of our database now in order to
restore the database we have to have a
database within the MySQL server with
that previous name and so let's go on
and create a database and this will be a
empty database so create database and
then you want to name it the exact same
name that it was before so employees
with a comma press enter just go through
and show the databases again we'll see
that we have that database there but it
doesn't have any data or tables or
anything in it we're going to get that
from our backup file so now that we have
everything set up we can exit out of my
SQL and let me show you the command to
restore the database so P sudo my SQL
and then we have to put our user in
there so roots and then- P for the
password and then we have to specify
that database that we just created that
empty database because it needs
somewhere for it to go it's not going to
just create that database for you it's
just going to modify that current name
database that we have in there to
represent what we had previously within
the backup so now we just put that left
arrow in there just like we did when we
imported before and then we pull in our
employee backup and press enter it's
going to ask us for our password we
don't need a password and press enter
and it'll go through and import all the
database all the tables and everything
within that database and then we'll
verify this back up once we complete
this I'll go through and show you guys
the tables that all the tables are
restored and pretty much everything the
data is there as well by running a
couple select queries so I'll be back
when this finishes all right and so the
import is done let's go in to my SQL and
check our database and just verify that
the tables are there and we can also run
couple queries to see if the data is
still there and so first off let's uh
show databases which we know it was
there before cuz we created it before we
logged out of the system and imported
our file now let's type use employee
database and press enter and then now
let's show tables and semicolon press
enter so as you can see we can tell
right off that we have our full database
back so like for instance I created that
audit table for the auditing so it has a
trigger associated with it so if any
updates to the employees table
departments column it will track it
within this a audit table that we
created so that's a Telltale sign that
we have our database back and that's
different from the original database
that I installed on the system and
actually let's just run a select on that
table right fast so you guys can see
that that information is back and so
let's go from
employee audit and semicolon press enter
as you can see it has all those records
there it hasn't changed so all our
records are back as well so we can do
the exact same thing by checking other
tables if we need to like this is the
employees table and we know from the
original database we didn't have this
column in here with the Department ID
and so that lets you know that this is
the database that we dropped and there
you have it you have successfully
completed my MySQL course and I hope
you've gained a valuable insight into
this powerful relational database
management system so whether you're a
beginner or already had some experience
I trust that you're now more confident
in working with mySQL and also MySQL is
a fundamental tool for anyone dealing
with data and your new found knowledge
will be an asset in various domains from
web development to data analyst and
remember the best way to become
proficient in myql is through practice
and so keep experimenting building and
refining your skills with determination
and dedication you can become a master
of my sequel so thanks for choosing my
course I wish you the best of luck in
your database Endeavors and may your
MySQL journey be filled with success and
of course keep protect okay